i got i have to do this because i want
to make sure we get to this and so i
have this is important to know too
this is another thing that people if i
mean i didn't know about this so
i'm glad we're talking about it right
now in china
there's a concentration there's
concentration camps they are taking
uh a group of people called the uyghur
muslims they are harvesting their organs
and selling them
they're harvesting their hair these
people are being
forcefully reselling americans
they so they were trying to they were
trying to trying to yeah big shipments
of fake hair what are the weaves no real
hair
no no no i mean i mean like like yeah
you're supposed to you think you're
buying fake hair you think you're buying
but it's actually
these these people who are being
kidnapped and put in concentration camps
right now by china
they're shaving their heads and selling
their hair to other countries that's
correct
they're harvesting their organs they are
forcefully sterilizing these people
check out this story from the ap china
cuts uighur births with iuds abortion
and sterilization
this is just absolutely insane it's
crazy
the chinese government is taking
draconian measures to slash birth rates
among uyghurs
and other minorities as part of a
sweeping campaign to curb its muslim
population
even as it encourages some of the
countries han majority to have
more children so we we can come back to
this
but i gotta i gotta give a shout out to
majid nawaz follow him on twitter it's
m a a j i d n a w
a z he's engaging in a hunger strike
i believe he's on day three now he said
please do not ignore a muslim genocide
for the second time in my life
i'm already out of anger and no longer
feel pain i am asking for some love
and then he posts these uh these
petitions majid is a
a very high profile um radio host
for it's what's it called lbc and is he
still doing it
he's got a show i don't know what lbc
stands for what is it london broadcast
company
probably something like that and i got
to say i think what magic do
is doing is one of the bravest things uh
in order to spread the word
uh explain to people what's going on
sign petitions rally people to start
talking about what china is doing more
and all all this amid the backdrop of
just everything bad that china's been
doing to the united states
that trump himself has been calling out
and now majid is an intellectual dark
web type personality okay
i say type because i don't know if
there's a formal group
but magic definitely is my understanding
is that he actually coined the phrase
regressive left
referring to like social justice
warriors and stuff and now he's
basically come out saying
we we cannot ignore what's what's
happening right now
and you know what it's got to be said
it's got to be said
how many activists on the left have said
what you know if you've ever wondered
what you do during world war
ii you're doing it now because of trump
and because of
immigration no it's because you're
ignoring the
the horrible atrocities that are
happening
right now in china we have we have video
oh yeah so i don't know how is there
anything there's nothing like graphic or
anything in this is there no no no no
you can show it it's uh
it's it's an aerial uh drone footage
from uh someone
what they they call uh unknown hero in
china which i
100 agree because people need to see
this because this exact footage
look at this man is showing something
hauntingly familiar
from world war ii and and just i mean
you could just play it like look at them
they're all just sitting there
in lines being rounded up corralled and
put on
trains onto trains and and
man this is heavy dude seeing this stuff
it's like this is going on
right now people are living it we are we
are living it right now and if you don't
know about it
you better know about it now because
this is happening they're harvesting
these people's organs
they're trying to sell their hair to
americans because they're all shaved
their heads
have all been shaved that's right they
are this is this is
this is horrendous and this is a nation
of what 1.4
1.4 billion people believe so this is
one of the scariest things we face as a
planet right now
honestly i i i am upset it's uh
it's hard to see this and know that this
is going on and that nobody here
it's just this oh well coronavirus
no no no no no there's genocide right
now that's happening
yep this is crazy footage man and you're
buying
and wearing their hair we are lucky that
whoever was able to pull us off
it looks like they're actually filming
the the screen
of their drone controller i wonder how
the chinese
didn't catch this you'd think they would
have locked this down
hard well because they probably sent it
off hoping someone was gonna get it and
be like please i hope someone finds this
you know what what else can they do it
could be an intelligence agency that
actually leaked the footage too like
something of you know of better means
because yeah
see the zoom capability yeah that's a
that's high
i mean it may just that's not digital
zoom that looks like optical zoom to me
so i wonder what kind of drone they're
using maybe people in the comments might
know
but it's right there man all those
historical photos we've seen of people
being loaded onto trains
yeah i remember watching uh they did
some commercials
where it was like do you remember this
there was like commercials of like a it
was like a suburban white family sitting
in their living room
like watching tv and then all of a
sudden like full camo people like kick
the doors in
run in and then grab them and they're
screaming like on the ground now and
then it loads them into a truck and then
all sudden
it freezes frame and then turns black
and white and turns into a photo from
world war ii germany
they did like and they were like what
would you say something like that
it's happening right now i gotta be i
gotta be completely honest i don't even
know where to begin
so that's why i gave a shout out to
imagine nawaz he's doing a hunger strike
and will that be enough i don't want to
be pessimistic
but i don't know i mean it certainly got
us talking about it which is really
important i mean i'm looking at the
comments
not a lot of people know about this i'm
glad about it like
what so where are you kidding me when
trump says
china yeah we're not playing games no
this is it's crazy because you can go
back to like 2010
and trump's talking about china you're
right he is and then you know what the
so um there was what was it michael
flynn was talking to
2000 he was talking about it oh yeah
he's been talking about they've been
extracting
our manufacture would you say 80 percent
of our manufacturing as it stands right
now
80 of us imports imports
all imports come from china 80 percent
i was reading something about why
michael flynn was targeted
in the mueller investigation and
apparently it was because he said
that he didn't think russia was our
biggest threat that china was
wow and then they were like oh no he's
trying to protect russia
it's like maybe maybe he was right and
china is the biggest threat but it's not
just about what's going on with the
weaker muslims man it's hong kong
yeah you're right man hong kong is
is essentially my understanding and i
could look i'm not from there
but is that it's basically english
common law or it's been for a long time
they've enjoyed free speech
yeah free expression democracy well yeah
democratic institutions right i don't
know exactly
parliamentary system i'm not entirely
sure but then when the uk basically
said they're no longer going to be a
colony they said you know there you go
china she's all yours and what does
china do
they said oh it's going to be fun we're
going to keep hong kong the way it is
nope
they have basically given themselves the
power to to rendition
hong kong citizens completely just in
secret literal black bags dragged off
and so this brings us to you know donald
trump's executive order
yep which we did talk about yesterday
and now we'll talk about in the context
of all of this
i'm actually surprised there's not a
harder and more serious executive order
on the uyghur
concentration camps same here i i i
i it's an atrocity to humans it's one
human rights worst atrocities probably
in the history
in modern history hands down no doubt
about it
and the scale is what's scary because
you know can you google search like how
many people
lived in germany in you know 100 years
ago
because this is we're talking about 1.4
billion people in china
yeah but the amount of people in these
camps
i'm not sure is it a million i think
it's that's what i was thinking it was
about a million but i don't know i don't
have the exact number i'm just saying
like
when when now that there's more people
on the planet and populations have
expanded we're dealing with a massive
scale of widespread human suffering
and that's i mean forced sterilizations
yeah of people
so so i was reading about why they're
harvesting organs
and apparently what it is other wealthy
muslims
can't have organ transplants unless it's
right so china's basically like hey it's
like the movie the island
start a farm of halal humans for them
that's straight up what they're doing
that's what it is
it's a human farm yeah so um
for can't stand it no i'm sorry i'm
looking at the wrong chart you've seen
have you ever have you guys ever seen
the movie the island i have yeah we just
watched it recently actually
it's a bunch of clones who don't realize
that they're
just gonna have their organs harvested
for wealthy people who got themselves
cloned
and now i wonder you know how is china
treating these people
as commodities as products to be sold
what do we do that's what they are you
know i was talking to someone about this
and
and their response to me was like okay
what should we do ground war in china
and i'm like man i don't know sanctions
i guess well we're doing that yeah
that's a good point
that was the beginning so right and
that's why i think war with china is
inevitable
i agree i think i i was talking to a
friend of mine today i was like i've
never been
more sure of of us going to war with
china than today
listening to uh bill barr talk about
china
calling them out calling apple out
calling hollywood out
calling all these specifics that was
today right that was today at once and
bill barr went
ham and if you if you didn't listen to
his interview or
it was a speech that he was giving at uh
gerald uh ford
or something um you must
it is an absolute must call them
collaborators be aware
of what they're doing and what they're
talking about it i had to listen to it
twice
because i couldn't believe it he called
them collaborators right or like alluded
to them being collaborate or something
i have it right here pull it up it's a
long speech i
i it's it's quite long i have the words
written here i'm just uh
he was basically talking about hollywood
injecting propaganda yeah
he was talking about you know the nba
these big tech companies
gladly just being pawns for the
communist party of china
yep basically having this double
standard of
well america we you know we don't really
care about you
we have to cater to china because they
have way more people
and we make way more money on on their
citizens
and he calls them out for it it's like
oh you don't care about freedom of
speech you don't care about uh
civil rights real crazy civil rights
being
violated what did jack dorsey say to me
last year on rogan
about their rules what do you say the
globals they're trying to trying to
apply like a global standard right is
that is that that's what it was right
or something like that it's like oh well
you know what he talks about global
company he talks about that in here no
you're not a global company nope
how many countries in the world have
human rights protected by their
constitution
very very few and certainly not china
definitely not look at how desperate
these companies are to function in china
google wanted to do some kind of
censored search that
exists in the country and the response
was well if we don't do it someone else
will so we might as well
no it doesn't work that way china
doesn't just end by saying like okay you
can exist here
what did bill boss say about the iphone
remember that part
he said they well specifically was
talking about um
the guy that attacked the courthouse in
california and
he had two phones on him and he
went to shoot the phones and they took
him out before he was able to shoot them
completely
and they were trying to get into the
phones and they were like
they got a warrant they actually went
and got a warrant and went to apple said
here's our warrant
let us into this phone and they were
like nope sorry we can't help you like
that's
against our policies like we won't do it
and they were able to get into the phone
and that found out that they were there
was connections to al-qaeda
wow and it's like wow did i just did i
just hear that like is that actually
happening
so i actually found this uh well so i'm
just gonna read this one part go ahead
you want to finish that point yeah the
point was he said you couldn't sell
an iphone in china unless china had
backdoor access that's exactly it yeah
he did say that
right so the point was we can't get in
these phones but you think china would
allow them to sell in their country
unless they had backdoor access
exactly so when when the united states
government says if you're going to run
encrypted software messaging we need a
way in it doesn't work that way
right you create a way and everybody's
got to weigh in but
he's basically pointing out that because
of
you know because of the the rules the
rights the constitution that we have the
fourth amendment
apple will say a few but do you think
when it comes to china
nope i'm sure the ccp is given a golden
ticket listen to this
the people's republic of china is now
engaged in an economic blitzkrieg
an aggressive orchestrated whole of
government campaign to seize commanding
heights of the global economy
and to suppres surpass the united states
as the world's preeminent superpower
period
thucydides that's straight up from what
he said and it was like
man when he when he said that i was just
like bro dang man there he's calling him
out and that's
that is what i'm seeing i got a deep
dive for you on your saturday show
what's up
thucydidestrap okay yeah maybe this this
uh
i'm gonna do i'm gonna dive into trump
this this uh saturday
and and it's good i mean people need to
know about the type of person he is the
things that he's actually done and i'm
gonna i'm gonna talk about it thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you